hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the paradigm of lung cancer
from therapy selection to resistance
monitoring
i'm susie valdez of labrutz and i will
be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by agilent
to learn more
visit them at agilent.com we encourage
you to participate today
by submitting any questions you might
have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
antonio
mark cady a full professor of pathology
and director of the inter-departmental
center of advanced molecular diagnostics
and innovative therapies at the
university
of getty pascata italy dr
macketti you may now begin your
presentation
hi good morning
good afternoon to everyone everywhere
know that you are many as you can see
from the title
my presentation will be focused
on the molecular characterization of
nose muscle lung cancer
to select patients for targeted
treatments
as well as to monitor patients during
treatment
by evaluating the presence of resistance
in using mutations
using state-of-the-art technologies and
in particular next generation sequencing
we will speak quite a lot of net
generation sequencing today
um
okay lung cancer has been one
of the first human types treated with
targeted therapies
and nowadays precision oncology has
become the standard of care
for oncogene driven muscle cell and
cancer
actually the story started several years
ago
in 2005 with the introduction
of egfr mutations as markers
of sensitivity to first generation
tyrosine kinase inhibitors
such as gefitinib and herotinib
and then second generation and third
generation tyrosine kinase inhibitors
including a fatty nyphenosine
americanism respectively
in the following years several other
biomarkers
have been introduced in clinical
practice
arc one in 2011
ross won five years later in 2016
behalf one year later and then in 2019
2020 we have an explosion
of other biomarkers including
fusions instruct gene family
in fact 1 2 3 fusions and red
fusions skipping of exon 14
of the med gene f2 mutations
mainly insertion duplications and gene
copy number variations
of l2 and then
k-ras mutations and so on
you see here in red numbers the
prevalence of these genetic alterations
in osmosis cancer in europe
and in western countries
since these mutations are mutually
exclusive events
in the whole more than 40 percent of
patients
have one or the other of these
alterations
actually the prevalence in asiatic
countries is even higher
mainly due to the higher frequency of
visual fire mutations
in non-small cell and cancer in western
country the frequency
is about 13 percent whereas in asiatic
countries
is more than thirty percent so in
addition countries the vast majority
on osmosis and cancer are
oncogene-driven cancers
as you see here more than 20 different
drugs
are nowadays available for treatment of
these patients
so we could summarize the situation
stating that we are
in the presence of a very complex
diagnostic assessment
and very complex clinical management
of nosmal cellulite cancer patients
and the situation could be even more
complex if we consider
immunotherapy and the markers for
immunotherapy
pl1 which is the widely
used markers uh for
specific patients and but other
matters such as microsatellite
instability human mutational body
are coming for the selection
of patients immunotherapy
so very complex scenario
now
what is the role the pathologist in the
era of this new generation drugs
i think that the pathologist plays a key
role
in two different moments
first a clinical diagnosis for
the detection of sensitizing mutations
and this is done mainly on tissue
samples
the pathologist uses plasma samples
only when tissue is not available with
diagnosis
the second key point is that progression
for the detection of resistance-inducing
mutations and this is a very important
key point
in this case plasma for the analysis of
circulating free dna
is usually more important than tissue
since it is more representative of the
metastatic diffusion
so the rules are tissue is better than
plasma the clinical diagnosis
we whereas plasma is better than tissue
attraction however
in some cases a mutation present in
tissue
cannot be detected in plasma
this occurs mainly in patients with
locally advanced disease
if you have a patient with a diffuse
disease it's much easier to detect the
mutation in blast
but if the mutation is localized
thoracic locality disease
in this case is much more difficult to
detect inhibition
and you can detect it only in 20 25
percent of patients even with a
more sensitive technologies so
when a plasma test is negative then
tissue
should be should be used to confirm the
results
at clinical diagnosis i think that
we can state that it's almost all about
tissue or cells
we should concentrate on tissue or cells
we get samples as resected tumors
at surgery in about 25-30 percent of
cases
only 25-30 percent of patients are
eligible for surgery
in the case of resected tumors the
amount of tissue
is not a matter but
tissue should be well preserved you can
have a lot of tissue
but if you do not preserve it very well
you cannot you can do anything with this
a
large amount of tissue so we have to be
careful with preservation of the tissue
in the pathology
department fixation and
conservation story
in the other cases and it represents
about 75 percent of cases
we get tissue biopsies or psychology
specimens
in these cases in case of tissue
biopsies or cytology specimens
the amount of biological material is
usually
very limited this is sometimes
really challenging
so for tissue viruses or cell samples
an efficient management of the biologic
material
is mandatory as you see in this scheme
when we have a limited amount of cells
or tissue
first of all we need to perform a
morphological
and immunophenotypical characterization
of the tumor
by using the minimum amount of tissue
just few slices no more than two three
slices
so the rule is do the mass with the mean
try to get the maximum with a minimum
amount of tissue
then we need to characterize the tumor
for biomarkers
that include predictive immunostore
chemical biomarkers
such as pdl-1 for immunotherapy but also
r1 ros 1 in terms of expression
and several genomic markers that need to
be detected
all together in a single test
possibly finance generation sequencing
we need to test all the biomarkers
together since there are cases
like the one you see in this slide that
show
concomitant alterations
in this case for instance the patient is
alpha and positive
and pdr one positive it's a rare case
but can happen and the oncologist
needs to know the whole situation
in order to accurately treat the patient
so it is extremely important we evaluate
all of the markers the tumors markers
together
in a comprehensive report
this is the reason why next generation
sequencing
a multi-marker test
is becoming more and more important as a
diagnostic tool
the molecular analysis that progression
is mainly based in
on plasma samples which are more
representative as i say
of the mutation status in patients with
multiple metastases
also in this case ngs is the best method
for the detection of the many different
mutations
involved in the acquisition of acquired
resistance
actually we have dozens and doses of
different mutations involved
in lung cancer acquired resistance
so once again also for
plasma regulating tumor dna
ngs is in pool position as a diagnostic
test
next generation sequencing which is
better and defined as massive parallel
sequences
more than two years ago i started to say
that
we should use the terms massive parallel
sequencing instead of
nest generation sequencing that doesn't
mean
anything but next generation sequencing
is so diffuse
to term to indicate this technology that
we
we cannot remove it now so i will say
next generation sequencing
next generation sequencing can allow to
detect all the different types of
genomic mutations we need to know
for the treatment of patients in
clinical practice and in clinical trials
including as you see here a single
nucleotide variance
insertion and deletions copy number
variations
translocations fusions
together with many other applications in
transgenomics
epigenomics that represent the near
future
of ngs so we are in the presence of a
very versatile
and powerful technology ngs
there are two major sequencing
strategies
one is based on pcr amplification
for target enrichment the so-called
amplicon sequencing actually
i don't like this type of approach
especially for formally fixed
paraffin and better samples since by pcr
amplification
we can introduce sequencing art
difference we have worked
quite a lot in the past with sequencing
artifacts you will
you can lose a lot of time with
sequencing articles
nowadays many strategies
have been adapted to reduce pcr induced
artifacts but
if possible it's better to avoid them
how can we do it but
a second approach the second approach is
based
on hybridization in capture
of targeted regions this latter approach
in my opinion can give us more accurate
data
especially on paraffin embedded samples
anyhow both approaches are used to
prepare genomic libraries
that then must be sequenced and
sequenced
by ngs
here are several commercially available
ngssa for the analysis of dozens of
biomarkers
we can define this ngssa reported in
this table
as small gene panels
since um those and struct
genes are investigated by these panels
and they are frequently used now in
daily diagnostics
in many labs everywhere in the world
they can be used on
formally fixed paraffin embedded tissue
or plasma as you see requiring
dna or rna for analysis
large panels including hundreds of
genetic markers
are also available you see here
panels including from about
100 to more of 1000 genes
some of these panels can allow also the
detection of additional
alterations including microsatellite
instability
and tumor mutation on garden which can
be used for markers that we say
for the selection of patients for immune
immunotherapy large panels
give us much more information and can be
useful particularly for the management
of patients
in clinical trials so at this point
more panels are mainly used
in daily practice large panels
for clinical drive assessment of
cleaning or mutations
alterations for clinical trials
at this point question
is important test in house
or send it out in fact samples can be
tested
by next generation sequencing in-house
or send out to a reference laboratory
i think that there are a number of
parameters reported here
listed here that can influence
the decision including a highly cost
investment
for next generation sequencing
technology
the availability of technical and
bioinformatics expertise
the specimen volume a small sample is
better managed
in-house the turnaround time
requirements
decide to access raw data if you sent
out
the sample you don't usually get raw
data
in other parameters can be technic.com
so it's up to you these are quite
complex decision of course
but it's up to you
at the university of chiati italy
i lead the department of pathology of
the clinical hospital
hospitale clinic clinical hospital
which represents a referral centers for
molecular diagnostics in our region
we perform our test in-house and serve
many other centers
on our in our region
in our pathology departments we have
recently implemented
among other technologies the agilent
next generation system sequencing system
which is a hardware reagents and
software solution
dedicated to labs that need to perform
next generation sequencing analysis in
clinical practice mainly in clinical
practice
you see here a sort of timeline of the
agilent
ngs system implementation in our lab
from may 2019 through january
2020 by adapting and optimizing
different instrumentations and protocols
we decide to choose the agilent solution
since it is based on the hybridization
and capture technology we have spoken
about
the two type technologies and the fact
that i i
personally i like this kind of
technology
and agilent is a leader from the
beginning
for this type of technology in addition
agilent has recently introduced
the sew select approach which is based
on
the use of longer probes that tolerate
larger mismatches moreover
it uses enzymatic fragmentation instead
of
other type of fermentation of dna
reducing the
time of analysis and the amount of
required dna
i can say that 10 nanograms are
usually more than sufficient for the
test and that's
a good required for all the results for
all these
reasons we decide to go agilent
in next generation sequencing in our
diagnostic lab
in particular for lung cancer molecular
technologies
we frequently use the shoe select all in
one
lung cancer panel this is a
small panel
but extremely useful powerful panel
since it allows to detect single
nucleotide variants
and indoors in 14 clinically
important genes the ones i show you now
copy number of variations in several
genes
including meth and ac2 amplification
which are important alterations in lung
cancer and
translocation in arc 1 ros 1
red and track chin family
and trap 1 and fibroclastic refector
receptor 3
so for all
this reason i think that this small pan
is a very interesting very appealing
time
in addition to the standard all in one
panel
if you want you can get an all in one
custom panel
which is available and allows to select
biomarkers
for a panel of from a panel
of 110 genes allowing the detection of
12 different fusions and 18 copy number
variations
so you can choose the gene of your
interest
another interesting improvement for
acromagic
is the new ngs workflow
for clinical applications which includes
the
tape station for sample quantification
and qualification
this is an extremely important step
to evaluate the quality of dna extracted
from formal inferences paraffin embedded
sections
the quality of deception
and the quality of dna structure
extracted
is a is a must
to get a good maturation sequencing
run and the magnesium ngs station
a great improvement for preparation of
genomic libraries
that allow to automate all the process
you see here the safe station 4200
the station we use in our lab in the
pre-analytic phase to test our samples
for dna concentration
to test samples for the level of
degradation
and assessment of fragmentation
conditions
this is an essential steps as i say to
get reproducible
and robust results from our samples
i think that the test station is one of
the most accurate system available in
the marker
for these purposes and you see here
how the samples are
aligned and how constant are the results
and here you see the magnus library
preparation system
which has completely revolutionized our
laboratory
the system comprises hardware
which is a mechatronic system to move
the samples to pipette to share the
samples
software and chemistry solution to
completely automate the process
it can prepare eight libraries per run
up to 16 libraries per day which is
quite a lot
as i said it is a sort of revolution for
a lot
in fact if you go manually as you see
here
the nine hour workflow for library
preparation
requires 2.5 hours of amazon time
whereas if you automatically by the
marketing system
the 9 hour workflow requires only 5
minutes of in some times
so a great important difference
when time is of essence if you are
in hurry it is possible to run libraries
one after the other in a week for height
super automation
you see here a library
started on monday another
on tuesday another on wednesday
they can be and produce it one after the
other
and you can get several libraries and
several
run in a week
after library preparation the tape
station the same
stave station can be used to evaluate
the quality of the libraries
in this case we use the all-in-one panel
small panel formatting preset paraffin
embedded tissue samples
and you can see the eye quality and
consistency
of the samples processes you see these
samples
i think that it's very difficult it's
not
impossible to get results like this
manually so the magnet system
did a great work
and here the quality of samples prepared
from circulating free dna
to on plasma samples
also in this case not the consistency
of the results we obtained
we have recently used the only one
system
to accurately monitor patients treated
with anti-egfr
tyrosine kinase inhibitors for the
presence of resistance in using
mutations in plasma
and we have implemented and published in
this paper
as you see a new algorithm for early
prediction of resistance
in normal certain cancer patients very
important to predict
resistance very early so that
the oncologist can decide how to manage
the patient
so the all-in-one test was proven to be
very useful
also on liquid biopsy in our lab
but let's come now to some real-world
cases
tested by ngs in our laboratory
as a referral centers we usually test
more than
20 no small cell lung cancer samples per
week
so i will show you some of the last
cases
we have we have
investigated case one
this is the case of a young patient who
was diagnosed
as egfr and r1 negative in another scent
this patient was found to be arc one
positive
by fish in our center in this
it was a quite difficult case with
eyeballism
complicating defining
you see here high polysomic cells
that render the test very difficult
the patient started a treatment with
crisotinis
a first generation eki against r1
that was maintained for two years
then at progression it was treated with
alecting
a second generation tyrosine kinase
individual
for more than two years until he got
to a rapid progression with liver
metastasis
at this point we perform the only one
test
on a plasma sample on circulating free
dna
that showed a resistance in using
alkaline mutation
specifically a tc substitution at
nucleotide
3512 a well-known
inducing resistance mutation hyphen
inducing resistance
mutation on the basis of this finding
the treatment was switched to
lorelatinib
a third generation tki so
this patient did that first second and
third generation pci
according to the imitation ecardi
after one week patients started to
recover resulting
in about one year most lifespan
this is just to say the importance of
a test like this one during monitoring
the patient can be strictly monitored by
ngs
during treatment with different tyrosine
chemists
tyrosine kinase nucleus
2 and is another case that can allow me
to introduce you to another possibility
for ncf
this case shows the importance of an ngs
test
not only to assess predictive markers
but also
for tumor diagnosis in this clinical
case
three samples were obtained from a
single patient
sample one two and three that you see
in this in the two slides
sample one corresponded to a long
adenocarcinoma
a small well differentiated lung
adenocarcinoma
whereas sample two and three were two
metastatic lesions
in thoracically influence
temple two has an antenna carcinoma
astrology
temple three has a squamous histology
very difficult situation for a
pathologist
the only one test ngs test
revealed the k brass mutation in sample
1
in a p53 mutation in sample two
and three the same p53 mutation
this data indicated that the two
metastases
were not related to the in sample one
indeed another primary tumor
an adenosuremous carcinoma was later
found
by clinicians in these patients giving
rise to
the two different metastatic sites in
sample two
and three so the all-in-one test
allow to distinguish two different type
of concomitant tumors
an adenocarcinoma in an arduino squamous
carcinoma
based on different genomic alterations
and this is just one of several
diagnostic problems solved by ngs in our
center
so i clearly believe that ngs is
important
also for diagnostic purposes not only
as a predictive test
case three this is the case of a patient
from which a very small biopsy was
obtained
for molecular diagnosis the amount
of tissue was very very limited
the tissue in this case was so scarce
that we decided to test it directly
by the all-in-one and gssa
without any other previous analysis only
ngs at the beginning due to the
very low amount of tissue available
ejafar al-quan roswan
and beerus markers were found previously
to be negative
whereas this test the engines test allow
to detect
a clear lb2 amplification
yes because this test the all-in-one
test
can easily detect lb2 amplifications
just the moment
the tumor was then subjected to
immunoscopic analysis
you see here immediate chemistry
a strong immune reaction indicating the
expression of albitude
in many cells and followed by
fish analysis performed on the dhaka
omnis instrument
that confirmed the clear lb2
amplification
the patient was then treated with the
new drug inaudible
a new drug which is a combination
of constitutional plus heuristics so the
only one test was found to be
very effective in the detection of
earthquake copy number variation
in this patient
case 4 this is another case of a young
woman
with a metastatic diffusion of an
indifferentiated sarcoma with pulmonary
hormonal manifestations the tumor was
previously found to be egfr
at one plus one pdl one negative in
another center
we subject the case to the all-in-one
test
and we found and track one fusion
that allowed a treatment with a specific
larynx in it
very specific very efficient and
interrupt
finally i would like to show you this
case
in which we found initial fire
resistance mutation
acquired during treatment
the official far positive patient was a
long survivor
actually she was the longest survivor in
our series
she started with jafitinib in 2005
and she was treated for 11 years
until progression occurred in 2016
due to a t 790 ammutation
at this point the oncologist decided to
treat
her with osimotomy a third genera a
third generation ppi
a progression of the four years of
oximetrine treatment
we decided to investigate the tumor with
the all-in-one
ngs test that showed a c787s
mutation as you know this type of
mutation
can be located in cis or in trance
with respect to the t790 ammunition
these mutations are on the same allele
transmutations are located on different
alleles
these mutations are the worst
since they are resistant to combined
therapies
first plus third generation tki
unfortunately these patients
had a ceased mutations however the
patient was treated in our clinical
center
with an innovative therapy in a specific
trial
but for me now it's important to show
you how the all-in-one test
that could easily detect the t790
mutation and the c797s mutation
red and green respectively
located on the same layer which is
important clinically important
now we have recently performed a test
that showed that the power of ngs and
the diagnostics
we select 35 nozzle cell and cancer
patients
who were found to be negative for their
main biomarkers
egfr arc ross biroff
previously investigated by conventional
reverse transcription pcr test
in our or other laboratories
the dna of these patients was subjected
to the
all-in-one ngs test that revealed
in eight cases more than 20 percent
of the series of these patients
draggable mutations that were missed
with a single biomarker test
among them two issues of our mutations
including two tryptic deletions
not seen by a commonly used reverse
transcription pcr test for egfr
i will show you later something more
about these three deletions
two potentially treatable k-ras g-12c
mutations
there is a drag now to treat these two
rc mutations for us
a red fusion an insertion duplication
of lb2 and a new fusion
of a track one i think that this data
clearly indicates that if we do not use
ngs
we can miss several mutations that
nowadays
can be treated in clinical practice
and now i'll show you
the two deletions egfr deletions we have
detected
in these patients here you see
the two cryptic deletions that are not
detectable
with most of the conventional reverse
transcription pcr tests commercially
available
they are longer and located in exon 19
a little bit outside of the classic
deletion area
this is the reason why they are missing
by common tests
patients responded very well to the
multinationals
so it's a it's a petition to not to
detect this kind of mutations so
i would recommend the use of the
all-in-one test or ngs similar to the
all-in-one test
permutation analysis in order not to
miss this cryptic deletions
now we are investigating farting
this problem and we're trying to
to write a paper on this
now i'm coming to my conclusions
the characterization of normal cell and
cancer patients
in the last year has progressively
become a complex diagnosis act
the tissue available for diagnosis
is usually very limited
sometimes we need to recover to liquid
biopsies
since the tissue is too limited
the number of molecular markers to be
investigated has progressively
increased in the recent years
ngs analysis is now a must
for an accurate technology
characterization
dedicated ngs panels can identify
different type of genomic alterations
required for molecular target treatments
the workflow automation is very
important
and this is the only way that you
can favor the diffusion of ngs in the
labs
since ngs is a quite complicated
um test to be performed
and with this i'm finished thank you
very much for your attention
if there are comments or questions i'm
here
thank you and thank you so much dr
marketee
for that informative presentation we
will now start
the live q a portion of the webinar if
you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience members
dr marketing what hurdles did you
experience
for an established pathology lab
starting new
on ngs
a great question i think that
the main criticism
for an established pathology lab that
want to move
to ngs technology is the economical
investments
as i said before you need a capital for
investment
if you want to start an ngs activity
most of the genomic platforms already
available
today available are costly there are
hundreds or thousands of
hundreds of thousands of dollars
especially
if you need a height of technology
the cost for reagents is another point
that need to be considered
but it is not higher it is not higher
than the cost of reagents for a limited
number of single markets
actually in terms of reagents
you will save money at the end this
because you can access several
biomarkers simultaneously
so if a laboratory already has the
facilities to perform
ngs or it has the possibility
of an economical investment ngs is the
most convenient approach
the most convenient way to afford a
molecular diagnosis
nowadays another critical point
i think could be the end some time
and sometimes especially for library
preparation
and this until
in the past was a a very critical point
however with the aids of the automatic
platforms
today available such as the magnus
platforms
this problem is now overcome
thank you so much dr marketee our next
question coming in is a two-part
question
what was there before ngs
and was there a mechanism for early easy
diagnosis
or was it impossible to altogether
um what do you mean for every
easy diagnosis
we can go early but not very much at the
moment
early technologies is a very important
step
in pathology today
and a number of technologies
um are
now available mainly for the detection
of methylation
that could help us in detecting cancer
different type of cancer earlier
but um i think that
in the next year we will have something
more concrete at the moment
every diagnosis is still
[Music]
a matter of
investigation i think
thank you so much now when
should the patient go to the biopsy
plasma of
tissue and at early stage growth
or later phase of cancer further what is
your take on the accessibility
of the technology in the developing
nations like
india
like india
i don't i don't see
would you like me to repeat the question
yeah
sure the audience member wants to know
when should the patient go for the
biopsy plasma
of tissue should it be at early stage
growth or later phase of cancer
let's start with that part of the
question
i i think that
the question is still around the use of
plasma instead of tissue
for the detection of the different
alterations
and i think that
plasma can be used
but at the moment the use of plasma
samples has to be restricted
to the evaluation of the resistance
um early detection of mutations in
plasma for every diagnosis of cancer
is still a matter of
investigation as i said
there are interesting results developing
and there are
interesting trial and error trials in
great reason but
at the moment they think that it's too
early
to speak about early detection
mutations in plasma
thank you so much and the second part of
this person's question
was what is your take on the
accessibility
of the technology in the developing
nations
like india
and if you want dr marketee you can
write this audience member separately
and we can move on to the next question
if if you're more comfortable
i think the major part of this question
is what is your take on the
accessibility
of technology in in developing nations
so nations like third world countries or
ones that are in the development stage
what is your take on how they have
access to technology
in developing countries actually think
that in developing countries
and yes you know technologies need to be
implemented
of course but
[Music]
the most freaking program
in developing countries is just to treat
the patient
for in clinical practice
for using drugs that can be used in
clinical practice
so i think that in developing countries
uh ngs the ngs technologies
will be
will be activated later and possibly
now other technologies could be used
together with ngs and
with the implementation of ngs in some
centers
some large centers referral sensor
centers
could start the activity in developing
countries
but most of the surrounding centers
should
should continue using standard
technologies in order to
detect the common alterations that need
to be
tested to select the patients
thank you so much and dr marketee
how do you manage detection of fusions
not reported in the literature
can you repeat this question of course
how do you manage
detection of fusions
not reported in the literature in
research
how do you manage those detections okay
that's a very interesting question
at the moment the best way to detect
genomic fusion
is to use the high quality rna
to detect rearrangements involving
exonic regions of the genome
this could allow to reduce the cost
this can you can avoid difficulties
of sequencing large intronic regions
in addition uh this approach can allow
to distinguish
in frame transcribed gene fusions
versus out of frame fusions
giving us more accurate data for the
detection of real g infusions
so rna-based ngs
would be the preferred method for the
detection
of gene fusions in cancer however
good quality rename is not always
obtainable from formally fixed paraffin
embedded samples
this is the reason why alternative dna
based
ngs strategies have been developed
among these strategies they think that
the strategy developed by
algernon and adapted in the all-in-one
lung genomic panel
is one of the most interesting
approaches available at the moment
if a non-fusion is detected
with this type of test you can be quite
confident that the results are real
a problem can arise if you detect
another type of fusion
in this case i would suggest to confirm
the results by using the same approach
on messenger rna or
eventually another orthogonal method to
detect diffusion
so for this type of fusion not reported
in the literature the all-in-one test
can be used as a screening technology
that needs confirmation by
an orthogonal method
thank you so much dr marketing we have
time for a few more questions
how well is the interpretation software
of agilent
compared to other competitors did that
cover enough vus
ethnicity evidences and curation
databases
i can tell you that this software
is um is a good software
it's quite easy to use
and it has been improved
month after month and so i i think that
it will it will improve also in the next
month
so um it's it's a it's an affordable
software and easy to use that's
the most important thing and quite clear
especially and for the section of
gene copy number of aviation i think
this software has been
very important and also and
for the detection of mutations in plasma
so
um i think that it's a great software
not not open at all on my side
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
dr marketee what is your vision in the
future
for ihc over ngs technology
for cancer detection
i think that immunistic chemistry we
remain an important tool for cancer
cancer and cancer detection and
in addition i believe that next
generation sequencing
exists but it exists also next
generation in minister chemistry
i mean multiplexing university chemistry
i think that multiplexing is the
chemistry will become a very important
tool for the pathologist in the near
future
possibility to detect several diagnostic
or predictive biomarkers in a single
section
could be extremely important in cases
for which the amount of available tissue
is very limited particularly in specific
type of neoplastic diseases
including lung cancer for which only
small biopsy psychology material are
available
however i have shown in my presentation
also
the ngs technology will be
increasingly used by pathologists in
diagnostics
i mean for diagnostic purposes not only
to investigate different
predictive biomarkers as we do now but
to help the pathologist in the fine
characterization of tumor types
i think that the pathological
classification of tumors
will further change in the future
requiring
more genomic data to better understand
the main quality categories that
characterize cancer source growth
and diffusion so i think that
ngs will become an additional diagnostic
tool
for future pathologies that we require
genomics
as well as as protein expression data
i throughput immunes to chemistry i
throughput genomic analysis
that's the point dr marketing thank you
so much for your presentation today
would you like to provide our audience
members with any closing remarks
um just to finish i think that
and i think very much agilent
for the occasion allowing me to present
our data
and our diagnostic experience
we spend most of our time in the lab
making diagnosis in diagnostics
most of our level of our life has been
spent
in diagnostics so thank you
for your time and i hope that our
experience
could be useful for you if you want to
start with ngs
in the near future thank you to all
and thank you again sir for your time
today and for your important research
and i also want to thank lab roots and
our sponsor
agilent for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i want to also thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
bye